first of all the fine print here is that
this is what I would do if I was going
to start up do a start-up right now this
is not necessarily what you should do
but but you should try to take that and
extrapolate it i'm a i have a CS degree
i'm a software guy not all of your
software this is me a little software
slanted but i think it's a lot more
helpful to get a specific example that
you can figure out if that applies to
you or not versus trying to give you
advice that would work for everybody so
this is what i would do so first thing
is i would pick a problem that i
actually have doing a start-up is really
really hard and you've got to be really
passionate about what you're doing for a
lot of different reasons it's gonna be a
lot of long nights and a lot of ups and
downs and i find it's much easier to be
passionate about something that affects
me personally and something i'm going to
be able to use is going to affect my own
life I would find a co-founder a same
kind of theme doing startups really hard
and it's a lot easier if you've got
somebody else there with you somebody
else that's going through the same
things you are and that you can lean on
and that knows what you're going through
and that's really kind of like your
first sales job is to go sell your
co-founder get them to to join up with
you I would raise as little money as
possible fundraising totally sucks it is
not fun nobody thinks it's fun
especially the first time you go do it
maybe when you're a huge success or
something but it's not fun and actually
it's sometimes a bad influence and so I
think I would really try to raise as
little money as possible it's always
going to seem like the more money i have
this would just be easy it's usually not
true usually that's just going to let
you run really fast in the wrong
direction one way to do that is the
inter customers to pay in advance this
is a really good influence and it's way
easier to do than most startups believe
and so you just you know you just ask
them to pay you and if that you're
really solving a problem that's valuable
that they really want they will pay you
in advance and they'll give you some
runway to go do that they'll give you a
little bit of leeway another great trick
is just ask your customers to double
what they're paying you I just did that
with another startup that I'm working
with and they suddenly doubled their
revenue it was it was an amazing trick I
would have very few secrets I would talk
to as many people as I can about my
startup this doesn't mean that you if
you have something you're going to
patent you should disclose that or you
might have some things that you don't
talk about but in general I talked as
many people as I can because I find that
kind of like social media and the the
benefits the unexpected things that are
going to come back at you far outweigh
the negative things that might happen
from somebody trying to steal your idea
or something like that
I would definitely build mobile first
and focus on something that's mobile um
you know again this is assuming that I
could do anything I wanted to do so I
get to pick where I'm going to start I
would pick mobile because that's where
all the growth is it's like a rising
tide kind of thing it's gonna be easier
to get people to work on it it's going
to be easier to get pressed about it
it's going to be easier to get investors
to invest in it it's going to be easier
to get people to adopt it so so I would
focus on something mobile if I could
pick anything in the world I wouldn't
buy any servers hopefully I don't have
to explain that here and I would build
it on Ruby on Rails there's lots of ways
to get to the top of the mountain
there's lots of programming languages
you could use you could build a website
probably in any different language and
they probably could all do it well if
you did it the right way but I pic Ruby
on Rails and it's not really just about
the way Ruby on Rails works and that it
lets you do things really quickly and
fast but it's actually more about the
types of programmers that go and learn
ruby on rails and I find they're really
entrepreneurial and they're the kind of
people I want in a startup
you